Hurry up Hurry up Ushita-san
It's
reggae
After all
I think Ayano should play badminton
Stand up You have a
great talent
If you run away you won't be able to move forward no matter how long you wait
Here and there, I write every once in a while Your
body isn't springy, your dynamic eyesight Your wrist is flexible and you're left-handed
It's okay, it's
Tobu Horror It's a common occurrence
.  That's right,
you want a new member, don't you?
Maybe he's afraid of losing, or something like that
This kid is pretty strong, but he's only a
year old.
I wonder if someone is a sport
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah Badminton in club activities is
good
if it's something
like
my name